[Музика]
Привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звуть vitaly liqueur і мене
звуть oh, c'mon MA, ласкаво просимо, давайте
розпочнемо урок, ми вже говорили
про тіло та розум, тож давайте
продовжимо  знаю, Наталія була так засмучена нещодавно,
чому ви знаєте, що мій день народження був
1 травня, і я зіграла велику вечірку,
я запросив усіх своїх друзів, але Макс
не зміг прийти, чому вона не прийшла, що
сталося добре, він надіслав мені електронні листи  за два дні
до вечірки та скасував її, здогадайтесь,
чому я не знаю, можливо
, з ним щось трапилося,
добре, я поділюся цим електронним листом з вами добре,
тому давайте прочитаємо електронний лист привіт, Ольга,
дуже дякую за запрошення на ваш
день народження, але, на жаль  Я
не можу прийти сказав усміхнутися я прокинувся
вчора вранці і у мене болить
горло, нежить, кашель і температура,
моя мама подумала, що я застудився, тому
вона викликала лікаря, коли лікар
прийшов, вона перевірила мій пульс, виміряла мій
температура досліджувала моє горло  і
вислухала мої легені, вона сказала, що у мене
інфекція і я маю залишатися в поганому стані протягом
наступних трьох днів, а також вона
прописала мені ліки, які я повинен
приймати тричі на день протягом тижня,
о, це дуже сумна посмішка, схоже, він
не любить приймати таблетки Мені дуже шкода,
що я пропускаю вашу вечірку Сподіваюся побачити вас,
як тільки одужу біля Маркса Сподіваюся,
ви одужаєте, щоб розважитися на вечірці
love-love-love max I see wow I  мені так
шкода Макса, схоже, що він справді
має серйозний культ, так, ніби все,
що могло статися,
з ним сталося, я не бачу успіху, так що, як ви бачите,
сьогодні ми поговоримо про
різні захворювання, різні симптоми, тому
яйця та фарби  але перед цим мені дуже
подобається електронна пошта, тож давайте проведемо диктант,
будь ласка, візьміть аркуш паперу або ваш
блокнот і ручку чи олівець, тому що ми
збираємося написати диктант уже готовий.
Google допоможе мені, так, але який
це тип диктанту  буде
цікавий диктант, якщо ви  не
чуйте слів належним чином, просто використовуйте свою
уяву, намагайтеся вгадати слова, не
зупиняйтеся і продовжуйте писати добре, так що
це ваша дошка і насмішник, ви
готові давайте йти я прокинувся вчора
вранці і я мав ха-ха-ха
один  більше часу я прокинувся вчора
вранці, і вони були добре, тому я прокинувся
вчора вранці, і вони пили каву,
і я прокинувся вчора вранці,
і у них був Ронні кашель і AH, просто
дайте мені другий мм-хм, тому якщо у вас є
якісь зміни  будь ласка, виправте на місці
готові давайте йти
я прокинувся вчора вранці, і у них був
Ронні і кашель, і моя мама подумала, що я
застудився, моя мама подумала, що я
застудився,
моя мама подумала, що я застудився,
тому вона подзвонила
тому вона подзвонила молодець,
коли лікар прийшов, вона перевірила мене,
коли прийшов лікар, вона перевірила мене, коли
прийшов лікар, вона відколола мене виміряла
моя рука виміряла мій оглянула моє горло
оглянула моє горло і послухала мою
землю і послухала моє,
тому давайте перевіримо  разом я збираюся
виправити а  будь-які помилки якщо у вас є якісь
добре, ви слідкуйте за нами та перевіряйте з нами я
прокинувся вчора вранці, і вони були в
першій дорозі, тому нам потрібна стаття, будь ласка,
виправте свою помилку, якщо у вас
болить горло, нежить, виправте кашель
і  лихоманка
Браво молодець давайте продовжимо, моя мама
думала, що я застудився, це
правильно, тому вона подзвонила лікарю дивовижно,
коли лікар прийшов, вона перевірила мою
температуру ммм,
вона перевірила мій пульс добре, вона виміряла
мою температуру, тому
оглянула моє горло, все добре, і
слухайте мої легені ідеально, так що Ольга
, схоже, ви чудово попрацювали
вітаю вас, дякую, чому б нам не
показати всі ці проблеми
і все, що зробив лікар,
так, як ми вже згадували, ми
поговоримо про яйця  і фарби, але перед
цим давайте переглянемо частину тіла. У мене
є чудова ідея, як ми можемо
це зробити  буду б  я добре, це
цікаво,
тому, хлопці, якщо у вас немає нікого, хто
міг би вам допомогти, просто намалюйте контур
чоловіка у вашому блокноті добре добре, давайте
почнемо, давайте почнемо добре, я знаю, що це виглядає
смішно, але ми додамо деякі деталі зараз
і повірте мені  це ідеальний
навик для навчання добре, тому давайте закінчимо
малюнок,
їм потрібен червоний так, будь ласка,
я дам тобі серце машина це
така велика Ольга так
повір мені, це такі великі фантастичні губи
дякую тобі ніс тобі потрібен  вуха,
так, я слухаю вухами, а як
щодо брів,
так, фергус і вій
зуби як про хлоро брови
та волосся причина шия ніс і
це велике серце добре, але мені потрібно
щось інше, щоб дихати це мої
легені, ми дихаємо легенями, і
взагалі це називається грудною кліткою, коли ми
дихаємо, грудна клітка піднімається і опускається
так, погодьтеся, у вас є два Ом, так що це  з
твою лівою рукою все в порядку, це моя права
рука, а це твоя ліва рука, і
тоді люди зазвичай плутають руку і
руку, тому, коли хтось каже, що ти
даєш мені, дай мені свою руку, це рука,
яку ти тиснеш,
і п'ять пальців добре, що  буде
відрізнятися від того, що ми маємо на
ногах, які називаються пальцями, тому давайте назвемо
п'ять пальців, у нас є великий палець, вказівний
палець, а середній палець безіменний
палець і мізинець, скажімо, перейдемо до
нижньої частини тіла, так  давайте
перемістимо картинку гарний шлунок ось тут
ми перетравлюємо всю їжу Томмі так, чому
діти називають це животиком,
тому що вони люблять смачну їжу так, це
була твоя ліва рука, давайте з лівою ногою
так і у нас є коліна, коліно, і ми "  у
мене є ноги чи
можемо ми писати як один, так і множину, тому я
пишу їжа, це одна їжа і обидві
ноги Ольга Браво,
це як футбол, так, давайте бігати так,
так, і тост, як ми були готові,
згадали, так що ми маємо пальці на наших
руках і  пальці на наших ногах фантастичні
кажуть  Я сподіваюся, що у вас також є
готовий малюнок, тому, якщо у вас вже є
контур, додайте його до
деталей і позначте всі частини
тіла,
тож давайте переглянемо болі,
люди зазвичай плутають три слова, коли
говорять про різні симптоми, які
ми маємо  ache pain and hurt давайте запишемо
їх take pain and hurt ache я
хотів би звернути увагу на
написання слова, навіть якщо ми
пишемо CH з, щоб вимовляти це як ache, тому
повторюйте за мною
ache pain well done Я зашкодив Jenna right
to hurt  ще не в порядку, тому давайте звернемо
увагу на ці слова,
перш за все, давайте розрізнимо біль і
біль, скажімо, яйце — це легша версія
болю, біль зазвичай сильніший, а біль
— це загальне слово, боліти можна
скрізь, а також ви можете відчувати
емоційний біль  давайте розглянемо приклади,
наприклад, у мене болить нога,
як щодо йоги, у мене болить
лікоть, добре, у мене болить шия, або
ви також можете сказати: болить шия правильно, давайте
перейдемо до розмови про емоційність  біль ми
можемо сказати, що моє серце болить добре, або ви
можете навести приклад, ви мене чули
ой, твої слова мені боляче добре що
щось може бути дуже болісно або болісно
переживати добре і давайте зі
словом боляче, як Ольга згадувала, що вона
хотіла розтерти частинку  і вона була
абсолютно правильною, тому що це слово в
основному
є дієсловом або як прикметник, а не іменник,
тому давайте напишемо прикметник і дієслово так,
щоб боліти і боліти так, коли у вас
болить шия, ви кажете, що моя шия болить, ви
згадали, що  у вас болить
лікоть так, мій лікоть болить фантастично, і
ви пам'ятаєте, що ми згадували, що у
мене болить серце, тому моє серце
болить, зараз давайте подивимося на
слайди з різними болями, і ми дамо
вам одну хвилину  подумати над
малюнками та позначити їх,
давайте перевіримо разом, скажімо, ви бачите дві
фотографії, а зараз давайте почнемо з
першого з хлопчиком,
я впевнений, що це яйце
Томека так болить живіт, тому у нього болить живіт і у
нього болить живіт,
добре, болить живіт
Браво, давайте з дівчиною, схоже, у
неї болить шия, як ми
це називаємо, болить шия. Браво,
болить шия, я пишу це одним словом
чи двома словами одним словом болить шия
фантастично,
давайте продовжимо, тож поглянемо на
дідуся  о, дозволь мені здогадатися, у цього джентльмена
, напевно, у нього фантастично
болить вухо, у нього болить вухо, болить вухо, болить вухо добре, і
давайте подивимося на жінку, схоже, у нього
болить зуб,
так, у неї болить зуб, добре, добре,
давайте продовжимо, давайте подивимося на бабусю,
здається, у неї болить  біль у
спині так болить спина фантастично, а тепер
давайте подивимось на вчительку, схоже, у
неї жахливий головний біль, а
як щодо цього хлопчика, у нього болить
горло, бачите, ми не використовуємо тут слова яйце,
так що просто згадайте ці два  слова
біль у горлі добре так давайте повторимо
слова біль у животі болить шия Ейрік зуб
болить спина болить голова і болить горло
зараз я сховаю це слово
десь у своєму тілі а Ольга
ти згадаєш слова, які ти
з нами граєш
готова  отже мій головний біль буде тут,
так що болить, повторюй за мною
головний біль, ти просто пам'ятай слова
що тут головний біль і тут
буде зубний біль, хоча це
буря тьфу, я поставлю сюди свій зубний біль
так тут головний біль і тут  два ради
фантастичний Я покладу біль у шиї на
капелюсі, так що горіховий пиріг тут і що тут
болить голова, а тут болить зуб, а тут болить
шия, фантастично, а моя вона
буде боліти в спині, боліти в спині, боліти в спині, зубні болі в
шиї,
фантастичних і соус написав я буду  покласти
на мою ногу так ось
біль у горлі, шия болить голова біль у спині
зуб фантастика Браво тепер давайте складемо
ці слова в речення, зараз ви
бачите слайд і ми хочемо, щоб ви вибрали
правильний варіант або
моє коліно, щоб тортик було боляче, або подивіться фарби
Ольга що  це правильна відповідь
я впав і боляче — дієслово, яке
тут відповідає yes so I fall over and I
pohore my knee yes Браво, тепер
я продовжу з офіційними реченнями
[Music]
[Music],
тож давайте переглянемо номер один  боляче
заціпеніло  два - це біль, номер три - знову біль,
а чотири і п'ять - боляче, давайте
звернемо увагу на красиві фрази, оскільки
йога сказала, що немає болю, немає виграшу,
і ще один біль, ви можете
описати ситуацію так,
коли ситуація дійсно жахлива, і
це дійсно  напружений, ви можете використовувати цю
фразу, коли ви хочете сказати, наприклад,
я розповім вам про всі яйця та болі,
а ви розглянете подробиці
ситуації та пам'ятайте останнє прислів'я.
отримаю винагороду, тому я не бачу тут слова яйце
так, тож схоже, що коли у нас є
такі симптоми, як біль у шиї, біль у спині, ми
повинні використовувати його як іменник правильно, і в основному ми
зосереджуємось на слові біль тут і слово
боліти добре  Щиро дякую за
перегляд уроку Сподіваюся, ви
помітили, що весь новий словниковий запас і
всі взаємні прислів’я, пов’язані
з домом, матимуть інше
значення в реальному житті так, давайте перейдемо
до домашнього завдання, будь ласка, перевірте  записуйте
весь словниковий запас і створюйте власні
красиві речення про болі
, болі, і, звичайно, я сподіваюся, що у вас
є рулон шпалер, щоб грати в гру, ви
можете шукати більше словникового запасу, що
стосується частин тіла
так, згоден, тому дуже дякую  багато для
уроку, і ми побачимося наступного разу
до побачення, до побачення, всі до побачення
[Музика]
ти